Zack Tipton puts a new spin on records
nobody listens to anymore but his vinyl
isn't for the years but for the eyes
vinyl I glass frames there in the groove
literally the models carry famous names
from music Jackson Lennon and miles
their visual aids and sun protection
they're the recycled frames of the vinyl
eyes brand and they're more than just a
fashion statement every time somebody
somebody puts on the frame that they
know what they're wearing and it and I
hope it makes them behave in a more
environmentally responsible fashion you
know and when they think that something
that they're wearing is inspired by that
then it will influence the behavior Zack
Tipton studio and Budapest is stacked
full of old phonograph records when
laminated and cut out with a jigsaw they
become I glass frames every frame is
made here by hand just as the first
model was in the year 2000 I wanted to
make some some frames out of a different
material than metal and I was in the
workshop and I kind of looked over in
the corner and I saw my father's record
collection and I was like haha why don't
I just try making them out of that and I
took a couple and glued them up and cut
them out and then that's how the idea
was born Zack Tipton grew up in the
United States but since 2004 he's been
designing and producing in Hungary his
mother's home country now he's got 15
employees to help him
he finds his raw material in various
record stores around the Hungarian
capital Zack Tipton is also a record
collector in private for his eye where
he generally takes the leftover stock on
the bottom shelf if it's not coming from
here it'll come from old arm
distributors that went out of business
they couldn't tell the records the
market collapse factories went out of
business and they can't send them back
for recycling so these are tens of
thousands of Records just sitting in
warehouses a few hardcore vinyl fans
tend to view Tipton's designs with
skepticism oh it's on there I'm not too
keen on in my like records and I think
records should be listened to or maybe
hang them up on a wall I find it a bit
morbid to make things out of the negev
ish movie theater other music fans are
enchanted with the idea among them Elton
John Hollywood star Michael Madsen
rapper flo rida the band 30 seconds to
mars and american movie director Quentin
Tarantino music stars are both customers
and inspiration for the frames what we
like to do is just take a musician and
examine the the history that he lived in
what kind of style he wore or if we were
to make Jimi Hendrix I'm a frame how
would that frame look would Jimi Hendrix
where this art would Jim Morrison where
this frame Irish singer-songwriter Bono
has ordered a set of frames Zack Tipton
picked out a very special record as his
raw material
it's a vinyl that was pressed in the 70s
and he went to this concert that are
collected funds for Amnesty
International and he attended this in
June of 1979 and the research I did
showed that he was very influenced by
this Zack Tipton's company sells as many
as 500 frames a month to customers from
around the world the frame start at
three hundred euros the cases also made
a vinyl are included and a spectacle
stand sometimes people get really upset
because of the cultural damage hey
you're destroying great music and what
about these artists and all that but you
people have to realize that that just
like books or anything that that society
creates not every one of them is going
to be a masterpiece culturally not every
book is going to become a classical
piece same with vinyl Zack Tipton has
found a lucrative new use for old and
unwanted vinyl and given a whole new
meaning to the word groovy